hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll so
we've just been through an eventful
launch week for the book version of the
biggest ideas in the universe volume 1
on space time and motion that was fun
gave a bunch of talks and we had the
podcast last week the solo podcast which
highlighted one of the ideas from the
biggest ideas which was Einstein's
equation for general relativity the
equation relating space time and how it
curves to Modern energy things like that
and the payoff of that equation is that
you discover the existence of black
holes basically neither Einstein nor
even short Shield who went often solved
Einstein's equation immediately after
Einstein came up with it neither one of
them knew that they would were
predicting black holes they went to
their graves as it were not knowing that
black holes were predicted by general
relativity of course things changed Neil
Einstein died in the 1950s and in the
late 50s and 60s scientists really began
to understand what black holes are these
days as it turns out we observe them not
directly of course they're black we
can't actually see them give off
radiation but we absolutely know they're
there because we can see what effects
they have on the universe around them we
can image the matter giving off
radiation near the center of our galaxy
and other galaxies we can get
gravitational waves from two different
black holes in spiraling toward each
other and of course there's been
indirect evidence for a long time from
X-rays and quasars and things like that
so basically we're moving into an era of
black hole astronomy where we don't just
think about black holes but we observe
them using many different techniques and
use what we learn from those
observations to better understand the
whole evolution of the universe
with that in mind we're very happy today
to have Kiara mingarelli on the podcast
Kiara is a astrophysicist physicist
astronomer I guess who thinks about
black holes and how to detect them now
the great thing is that the way that she
specializes in detecting black holes is
not one of the usual ways Kiara is an
expert in what are called Pulsar timing
arrays and this is just a just a fun
idea it's one you'd be rooting for to
work out even if you didn't know
anything about how sensitive and
important it's going to be Pulsar timing
arrays basically come from the fact that
black holes and other things by the way
admit gravitational waves so it's really
what we're looking for is not the black
holes directly but gravitational waves
emitted by black holes and maybe some
sort of background other gravitational
waves from other sources but black holes
are probably black holes doing things
spiraling in you know swallowing up
matter those are the biggest sources of
gravitational waves out there and what
happens is these gravitational waves
pass by pulsars which are very tiny
neutron stars rapidly spinning and these
pulsars turn out to be really really
good clocks they emit their beams of
light in very very regular pulses so if
you have a big long gravitational wave
that passes by all the pulsars in our
galaxy that we're monitoring it will
slightly distort the timing of those
signals that we get from the pulsars and
you can figure out what kind of
gravitational wave it is so basically
you're using a bunch of stars scattered
through the Galaxy as a gravitational
wave detector which is not only a
surprisingly good way to detect
gravitational waves it's a completely
different wavelength range than we can
look at here on Earth so it's a
different kind of physics underlying
what we will ultimately see we don't
know as we'll learn in Kiara's podcast
we don't actually have a claimed
detection that we know for sure that the
pulsars have seen mean gravitational
waves but we seem to be very very close
it's very very tantalizing so we're
going to learn something about it
hopefully in the near future and we get
to talk about you know black holes more
generally could they be the dark matter
what did ligo find what does it all mean
once again a reminder that unlike myself
who is a theoretical astrophysicist and
likes to write down equations most
physicists out there are actually
looking at data collecting information
Kiara by the way is also a theoretical
physicist but she works very very
closely in the team that is looking at
the data from Pulsar timing and so it's
a it's a real sort of honest combination
of theoretical work and good old
observational work that's how we learn
about the universe so that's why you're
at the right place let's go
[Music]
thank you
Yara mingarelli welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you it's great to be here
we talked about black holes before in
the podcast and even gravitational waves
but there's never enough talk about
black holes so I agree I always like to
ask the black hole-oriented guests you
know how do you define a black hole what
do you think about it'll be different
for a quantum gravity person than an
astro astronomer I presume yeah so
that's a great question when I think
about black holes I think about water
coming out of a water fountain and I
think about the water going up and then
falling back in and itself and that a
black hole is going to be some sort of
ultra compact object although formally
mathematically it's a singularity this
point of infinite curvature of
space-time whatever that means I you
know in my mind's eye and in my heart I
feel like a black hole is actually a
thing it's probably a very small thing
but wait so what is the analogy why is
it a fountain so it's like the the light
coming out of the black hole whatever
that is like if you look inside the
Event Horizon of the black hole if you
could imagine being inside on the other
side you would probably see light coming
out being processed around the
singularity like water coming out of a
water fountain going up and then falling
back down because the water itself can't
ever escape so it might make a spray it
might kind of get close and then start
doing weird and wonderful Wiggles but
it's never gonna just take off and go
away it's gonna be like water going up
and then coming back down and on itself
so this is so that's the view from
inside the Event Horizon that's what
we're not going to get because we're
astronomers now today for today's
episode we're looking at the outside of
the black hole right yes and you know
we've we've come a long way like I don't
know how how has our thought about black
holes empirically like in the universe
changed since you started thinking about
these things professionally right let's
see so when I was starting to think
about block holes when I was a kid right
I would save my babysitting money to buy
Scientific American magazines and I
would take all the glossy photos and put
them on my wall next to Jonathan Taylor
Thomas and Jonathan Brandis classic yeah
you didn't that well my friends didn't
you know I had a few friends
um and so
the black holes are just kind of like
this they were considered very
theoretical right there was sort of
evidence from cygnus X1 There Was You
Know x-rays that were coming out of this
kind of compact source and it could have
been a black hole accreting something so
gaining material from Star around it and
then like that material getting hot and
ionized gas coming off of it emitting
x-rays like maybe that's what was going
on but it was still very kind of Fringe
to talk about black holes and I feel
like today it's very concrete if you
want to say so now we have evidence of
black holes merging we have waveforms
from ripples in the fabric of space-time
that they make which is incredible we
have images of supermassive black holes
if two of them that have been directly
imaged which is absolutely amazing so I
feel like black holes have gone from
something that's very almost science
fictiony to something that's very hard
science and just be clear I think that a
lot of us are a little too quick when we
talk about Imaging or observing black
holes we're never seeing light coming
from the black hole right we're seeing
light coming from things around it and
we're interpreting it that's right
absolutely so we see like normally
coming from an accretion disk around the
black hole so a material that's you know
kind of in an orbit around the black
hole with it and sometimes it feeds the
black hole and sometimes it doesn't and
sometimes that material can be part of
jets that the black hole can make can
launch the Jets and some people say that
those come from the black hole but
you're absolutely right Sean that a lot
of people get confused by the
terminology and think that the light is
coming out of the black hole it is not
right it's close to the black hole but
it's not people have probably heard of
the idea of Hawking radiation but
nothing that you're doing has anything
to do with Hawking radiation we're never
going to see Hawking radiation from the
black holes that you care about no
that's right yeah Hawking radiation
um is not something that we care about
right now now maybe you know when
boltzmann brains
a while wait
operating supervisor episode of Star
Trek the most recent episode of Star
Trek strange new worlds Had a boltzmann
Brain yeah you must have been delighted
now they got it completely wrong I mean
it's a great show I love the show but
this was like a god-like boltzmann brain
that's really just not probably he could
be I don't know anything is possible
maybe if you wait long enough I don't
think that was the simplest conclusion
for them to LEAP to that it was a
boltzmann brain but anyway so the people
were weirdly for a long time sort of in
the 20th century skeptical that there
were black holes like yeah I think that
I my childhood cutting out pictures of
black holes phase was in the 70s and we
already knew about sickness X1 yeah this
is the famous one but we didn't even
know for sure that that was a black hole
and people were really
they I guess they were properly cautious
but it was weird because they weren't
sure whether they could be made and in
fact it's just not that hard I mean
nature wants to make black holes is that
safe to say
yes I think that nature makes black
holes in lots of different ways right
and you know if we think about the
history of black holes how they're these
you know
I don't know what to what to call them
in layman's terms but if you just think
of them as like these you know weird
singular points and Einstein's equations
so they're the points where the
equations can blow up and so no one
thought it was actually real that maybe
it's just some sort of artifact like
maybe we didn't write things down
carefully enough or maybe we made an
assumption that we shouldn't have and
you know is it really possible to have
something that's like a black hole and
so I understand why people were
skeptical because you know as scientists
sometimes we make a lot of
approximations and sometimes it's fine
and sometimes it's not fine and so I
understand people being careful
um but then going back to these you know
Einstein equations what boggles my mind
right now is that if one of the
solutions I was black holes that means
that the other one would allow white
holes that's true what does that
means we can talk about that but that'd
be a very different episode than what we
have coming up this is yeah so this this
boggles my mind right now like how can I
believe one and then the other one
doesn't make any sense these the arrow
time that's the answer okay
I do know a little bit about that yes
did you write a book on that but you've
already you've mentioned that there's
different populations of black holes
right so there are ways that nature
makes them but they're different way so
like what we have again a lot of recent
new data and discoveries but before that
what was our expectation for what the
populations of black holes would be like
right so that's a fully loaded question
so maybe I'll start with how nature
makes black holes and how nature seems
to want to make black holes so if we
start with the very small end to
potentially primordial black holes so
there were potentially at the beginning
of the universities small fluctuations
and some of them could have been dense
enough to create baby black holes and so
those were never stars like there might
not have ever even been any matter or
baryons that went into creating those
black holes that it's just a kind of
blemish in the curvature of space-time
like that kind of black hole is all
curvature which is so strange to think
about but it's entirely possible
then there's the black hole and also by
the way zero evidence that that actually
happened yes but it's something we can
think about exactly and they could even
maybe be the dark matter who knows yeah
well exactly it could possibly be
because you could possibly get some of
them that are as massive as the ligo
sources right and so the first detection
from ligo was to roughly 30 solar mass
black holes and some people think that
those could be primordial black holes
those could have come from the early
Universe
um and maybe those are also Dark Matter
like maybe that's the missing matter in
the universe who knows right now it
feels like
that parameter space is being squeezed
pretty hard that it's very unlikely that
that's the answer but it's curious well
black holes exist and they're black so
that's good but it is hard to make the
right number of them to be the dark
matter is my impression exactly and
there's a lot of things you would have
to Discount like the lack of lensing
events okay sorry yeah say more about
that well that
um you know if if you have black holes
you can have light that's behind them
that gets lensed when they're traveling
on the way to Earth and if you were to
have so many black holes that they were
the dark matter they would create a lot
of these lensing events and there's no
evidence for this at all so I feel like
it's being squeezed in a lot of
different ways that there's a lack of
evidence and a lot of different fronts
for these black holes to be the dark
matter so there still could be
primordial black holes but maybe not
enough to be the Dark Matter yeah or
maybe not enough that are in that mass
range okay right it's possible that I
mean there's there's a a lot of theories
about different masses of black holes
that you can make depending on the
conditions that you had in the early
universe and what you believe but right
now the ligo mass black holes anything
from like 10 to 100 solar masses that's
really hard right now to get those to
explain Dark Matter okay so how do you
make them
so they come from the collapse of stars
very massive stars at the end of their
lives will undergo a gravitational
collapse and the remnant will be either
a neutron star or a black hole so the
neutron star is kind of a halfway phase
it's a halt that happens when you have
the electrons and the protons that come
together and make a neutron but there's
not enough pressure to make the neutrons
to continue to collapse there's a
neutron degeneracy pressure that's okay
you can use those words and we can
assume people know what it means but
anyways basically the neutrons you need
a lot of pressure to get them to you
know continue to collapsing into a black
hole to make whatever material is at the
center whatever Quantum description you
have of that whatever your equation of
state of that fluid or material or
whatever Quark gluon plasma you think
makes up the central object inside a
black hole it takes a lot of pressure to
get the neutrons to make to turn into
that kind of material so some of them
just stop there and they're about one
and a half to two times the mass of the
sun but if you can keep going then you
create black holes and then the cool
thing is that from black holes that are
you know 1 or 10 or 100 solar masses
they can merge and the final mass is the
sum of the two black holes minus five
percent for gravitational waves
so we're making
if it's if the thing that is collapsing
weighs roughly less than the sun it'll
be a white dwarf or neutron star if it's
enough bigger it'll make a black hole
yeah okay so we expect to have a bunch
of black holes that are more than one
solar mass yes and then if they merge
they can get up there exactly but the
fun thing I think is that there hasn't
been enough time in the history of the
universe to merge all the Stellar Mass
black holes that are roughly the size of
the mass of the Sun to make a
supermassive black hole okay what are
those so supermassive black holes are
around a hundred thousand to a million
and potentially up to 10 billion times
the mass of the Sun they are the biggest
black holes in the universe no one knows
how those black holes were made there's
of course a bunch of different formation
channels that you can imagine one is
that you had these huge gas clouds in
the beginning of the universe that just
directly collapsed into a black hole
okay but that's hard because it means
that none of that gas was heated none of
it fragmented to form stars that it just
kind of went and then created a
supermassive black hole and there you go
so that's kind of mind-boggling there's
an intermediate uh kind of theory where
you have the gas cloud and then it
collapse and it makes these huge stars
that live fast and die young and they
make kind of intermediate Mass black
hole so maybe 10 000 solar masses a
thousand solar masses and those all
quickly merge to make a supermassive
black hole how would we know is this
something we're trying to discover with
telescopes
I'm so glad you asked that yes so one of
the ways that we can find out what the
um what we call them seeds supermassive
black hole seeds are is by looking at
gravitational wave signatures from the
early Universe because if you do have
all of these merging intermediate Mass
black holes that are you know building
up to create a supermassive black hole
each merger will emit a gravitational
wave signature and so
um the laser interferometer space
antenna or Lisa between friends is going
to launch in 2034 and that is going to
be a huge ligo type instrument in space
and that will be able to detect
um those kinds of gravitational waves
okay okay we will be able to all right
that's this gets in it's interesting how
many things come together at once right
we need to talk about the astronomy of
making these things and then the physics
of detecting them yeah and so forth but
maybe tell me just a little bit more
about the nature each of these
supermassive black holes because they're
not rare right there's a lot of them so
there's at least one supermassive black
hole in the center of every massive
Galaxy and my own research is studying
supermassive black hole mergers so when
galaxies merge and we have lots of
snapshots of merging galaxies in fact
the jwst image that came out earlier
this week had Stefan's quintet Stefan's
quintet it was breathtaking galaxies
five galaxies getting close and two that
were actually merging so we know that
galaxies merge and it's also how we just
think the universe works there's this
hierarchy and you know galaxies get
bigger by merging with other galaxies
and so if that's true then there's
Central supermassive black holes should
also emerge and those create the
strongest gravitational waves in the
universe in fact there are about a
million times stronger than the ones
that have already been detected at high
frequencies so maybe to explain this a
little bit because the black holes like
let me let me ask it this way yeah we
use the words supermassive black holes
and they're the center of galaxies yeah
and I bet that in a lot of people's
minds the black holes are holding the
galaxies together right but they're not
they are not they are a significant
fraction of the map well significant
maybe one percent around one percent of
the mass of the Galaxy
um but you know it's interesting that
you say that it's actually also an open
question how did the supermassive black
holes get to the centers of galaxies was
was it that there was a Galaxy that
formed a supermassive black hole form
somewhere else and they found each other
in the early universe is that how they
were seated we say were they farmed in
situ that seems really hard to do so
that's another open problem how big is a
supermassive black hole how like how
many light years is the is the black
hole center of our own galaxy do you
know so let's see so we have a fun trick
uh the relativists units is to use
seconds for everything which is light
seconds so one solar mass is 4.9 times
10 to the minus six seconds okay so
that's how long it would take light to
Traverse the Sun
and so
in the center of our galaxy we have
something that's about four million
solar masses so it would take maybe 10
seconds at most for light to get across
the center yeah exactly if you're a
photon okay it'll take you less less
than that so for time yeah but what I'm
asking you is that's very tiny compared
to the size of a Galaxy right I mean the
even if it's one percent of the mass or
or less yeah it's much much less than
one percent of the size because black
holes are very massive so yeah how do
the two supermassive black holes find
each other when two galaxies merge why
why do black holes merge at all right so
that's a great question and it's also an
active area of research there's very
little known about the lives of
supermassive black holes mostly because
it takes so long for anything to happen
on cosmological time scales
so I've done a few calculations which
show that supermassive black holes will
merge in something like two or three
billion years but that's a sizable
function of the age of the universe
which is about you know 13 to 14 billion
years old so
um what happens we think is that your
two galaxies
um interact gravitationally their
galaxies start to merge and then it
takes a while but the black holes are
eventually slowed down in the merger
process by interacting gravitationally
with gas and stars and so the technical
term for this for experts that might be
listening is dynamical friction and the
black holes will then settle and the the
gravitational Center of this newly
formed Galaxy
um but unless they're interacted upon by
other forces they can stay there forever
basically in a stable orbit it'll take
many times the age of the universe for
the supermassive black holes to merge by
only emitting gravitational waves and so
they can get to within about a light
year uh separation but they will not
merge unless something else acts on them
I see so it's easy let me just repeat it
to see if I got it right so it's easy to
see why black holes would sort of sink
toward the neighborhood of the center
because there's friction right exactly
but they have because they are so tiny
astrophysically speaking they have to
get really close and we don't know how
they do that well we have a few ideas on
how they do that and so this is called
the final parsec problem for anyone who
wants to read about it
um and so the black holes the solution
to this merger problem is that you
realize that the black holes are not
alone right that there is gas and there
are still stars and so if you have
um some stars that are crossing the
orbit of the supermassive black hole you
know pair every time that a star
interacts with those two black holes
it'll carry away some energy in angular
momentum and so every time a star gets
slingshot out and interacts with the
black holes orbit and that way you get a
little bit less mass and so energy
that's in the system and it slingshots
it out if you have this happen enough
times then you can get the black holes
close enough such that they merge within
the age of the universe you can also
have a gas disc that develops around the
two black holes and the gas can torque
the black holes and make them merge in
that sense in nature it's probably a
combination of the two yeah okay yeah
but to add a fun you know breaking news
headline to this
some theorists have found in large
hydrodynamical simulations
that the gas disks can apply positive
torques which means that the black holes
get further away from each other instead
of negative torch which make them merge
and apparently it really depends on
um the properties of the gas disk around
them so we think that for realistic
discs
they probably merge but but you can make
them not merge yeah okay on a super
computer
so it's all of these different competing
effects but if you can get the black
holes to within a thousandth of a light
year then they do merge by emitting
gravitational waves quite rapidly so 25
million years with respect to the two
billion years that it took them to get
to the center of the Galaxy so the
really the last part is just noise well
this is really fun because it is a
glimpse into you know where the frontier
of astrophysics is these days right like
we know these supermassive black holes
are there we don't know exactly why but
we're also not just stuck speculating
right we have some combinations of
simulations and and Telescope
measurements that will help us figure
this out that's right that's right and
we if we find gravitational waves from
supermassive black holes then we know
for sure that they've overcome this
final parsec problem and then the
question becomes well how did they do
that I see because we don't know I mean
in some sense they did overcome the
problem because they exist right
supermassive black holes exist and uh
but we don't know whether they were made
directly or they were assembled
gradually and all these things
gravitational waves will help us sort
out yeah so as you're saying it'll help
us sort out the formation scenario of
the supermassive black holes but even
um today like if you had a merging pair
of supermassive black holes you'd know
that they had to overcome this final
parsec problem that comes from Galaxy
mergers so the first gravitational wave
story was at the about the formation of
supermassive black holes and then the
second story is now it's much later in
the history of the universe now they've
there's black holes in the centers of
galaxies the galaxies are merging what
do the supermassive black holes do and
it's an interesting reminder that the
universe is still kind of young it's
like still evolving right when that
picture came out of Stefan's quintet
there's it's five galaxies interacting
with each other I think that probably
people see pictures of galaxies and
figure that's more or less a steady
state kind of configuration but it's
really not these galaxies are moving and
bumping into each other and tearing each
other apart absolutely yeah and their
black holes are merging hopefully there
are stars being slingshot around there's
gas being funneled to the center there's
everything is very Dynamic but the time
scale is not a human time scale and so
we see it as being static basically
right but if you just hit fast forward
you'll see you know really beautiful
physics happening and that's one of some
of the power of the super computer
simulations that you can speed up
mergers and then actually try to get
snapshots of galaxies that you see today
in different parts of the merger process
to be like does this fit like have I
seen this part of the merger in space
and then you kind of look at pictures of
space and you're like oh yeah oh yeah
there's that Galaxy there so you're
using pictures of different galaxies of
different stages of their life as a
proxy for the trajectory or history of a
single thing exactly because that's all
that we've got right yeah yeah we're not
going to wait around for a billion years
to watch what happens right no no no so
we kind of knew or we had strong
feelings that these supermassive black
holes existed long before any of this
gravitational wave stuff okay that's
right yeah right and is that I I
honestly don't know the answer to this I
presume that's because we knew that
there were quasars and things like that
and we're just trying to explain that
so that's part of the picture absolutely
but there's also the center of the Milky
Way right and so they're Andre I guess
and her group at UCLA have very famously
measured the mass of the black hole at
the center of the Milky Way and
um that Sagittarius A star which was
recently enriched with the Event Horizon
telescope and so by watching stars orbit
around this Central compact object
without giving it a name they could
figure out what the mass was just by
doing some very simple Kepler's laws
calculations so if you know the mass of
the star and then you know roughly what
its orbit is and you can watch several
orbital periods you can get a really
good handle on what the mass of the
central object it's orbiting is
and we don't see a lot of photons coming
from the center of our galaxy right it's
a pretty quiet black hole right now it's
a pretty quiet black hole
um there is evidence though that they're
at one point in its history had some
Jets there's some gas that people have
been able to see which would indicate
that at one point there were jets coming
from Sagittarius A star but this is very
speculative right we can only say like
this is consistent with the existence of
jets at some point in the past but you
can't rewind the universe to check but
we do see that distant galaxies are
often like very bright that's what a
quasar is right it's it's a tiny Speck
in space that is giving off way too much
light and eventually we realized it was
sort of a jet being beamed right toward
us from a black hole that's right from a
supermassive black hole super massive
block that's right yeah and so those
were all over the place in the earlier
universe and now we're entering our
adulthood and we don't have as many
quasars that's right yeah yeah and does
yeah yeah the universe is is changing a
little bit and so it's at least a
consistent story that our galaxy used to
have a quasar in the middle
that's right and also if you think about
it in the early Universe there was a lot
more gas and today there's a lot more
stars right that gas has become stars
and so even if you want to hearken back
to the final parsec problem it's
possible that earlier on in the universe
it was solved through gas interactions
through these torques and that today for
nearby emerging supermassive black holes
it's mainly Stars this makes me ask a
question because I know we're going to
get this question what about the Dark
Matter here because you know you're a
grown-up astronomer you know there's
dark matter in the universe more than
there is ordinary matter does that play
any role in making black holes is it or
is it just irrelevant
it's a tough question
um
there are different kinds of dark matter
there's not just one kind of dark matter
so one
um kind of dark matter that I think is
very popular right now because just like
everything there's different Fashions
and Trends in theoretical physics and
astronomy but there's something called
super Radiance okay and so what happens
is that there's these particles which
are created around the supermassive
black holes and the creation of this
particular kind of dark matter like
particle this Axion spins down the
supermassive black hole and so if you
watch one long enough you could actually
see it spin spin down so sorry just to
get this straight this is because axions
the Axion field exists in the universe
or is this literally because there are
dark matter axions if there are at all
yeah axions are still hypothetical but
yeah is it a bunch of like a cloud of
axions near the black hole or helping it
radiate yes okay the
xeons that are around the supermassive
black hole in fact it happens around
Stellar Mass black holes it's just these
clouds of axions can exist around black
holes and they can in fact I believe it
make gravitational waves as well kind of
like a large gravitational atom where to
go from one state to the other they emit
gravitational waves if you can imagine
that kind of funky
gravitational atom system
I can imagine it but I'm certainly not
an expert but let's let's be kind to our
listeners and explain a little bit about
gravitational waves like we've been
using the terminology and I'm sure that
they've heard the terminology before but
let's try to explain what a
gravitational wave is when I say that's
I mean could you do that please of
course so gravitational waves are
ripples in the fabric of space-time that
travel at the speed of light
and gravitational waves change the
distances between objects so you and I
uh are sitting a little bit a very
little bit a very little bit so you know
by the fraction of the size of a proton
for uh a ligo style gravitational wave
so you and I are sitting at opposite
ends of the room for example so we would
still be standing in place but we would
get closer together and then further
away and then closer together and then
further away without actually moving
because it's the space time between us
that's changing
and so with ligo
the ligo gravitational wave detector can
detect gravitational waves that are at
hundreds of Hertz and so if you could
hurts yeah per second yeah yeah
that's right it's got to be you know I'm
sure most people know what it hurts is
but just checking yes we have a very
educated uh listening population
um and so you could actually hear those
if your ears could hear gravitational
waves they would go
um
when they merge and make that chirping
sound
um and so it's it makes sense to think
about the change in distance
over distance when you're thinking about
those kinds of gravitational waves
that's really how we think about the
strength of a gravitational wave the
technical term is the strain but it's
just how strong that gravitational wave
is how much does it distort the fabric
of space-time so you can think about a
change in distance over distance and for
ligo this is you know the fraction of
the size of a proton over a few miles
and the miles are the distance between
the sort of ligo laser is moving exactly
okay exactly and so that's the strain
but if you think about so sorry wait let
me just make sure I understand this
because the point is that uh there's
this uniform stretching of space almost
uniform but uh what that means is the
further away a laser moves before it
bounces back the more the Distortion of
space is and the invariant thing is the
Distortion divided by the distance
exactly that's distance divided by
distance exactly yeah so it's this that
change in distance over distance is the
strain and that is something like the
fraction of the size of a proton that
the gravitational wave changed over a
few miles right okay which is not very
much crazy small exactly the fact you
should give a Nobel Prize to the people
who did that they should absolutely
absolutely if we were Time Travelers we
could go back to 2017 and make sure that
that happened
and so ligo is the famous experiment
that did win the November that's right
that's right
um and so
changing the distance you know thinking
about distance changes makes a lot of
sense for ligo in that sense but there's
other gravitational wave detectors
and the one that I work on is called the
Pulsar timing array but it's the same
idea you look for
these space-time distortions but with a
pulsar timing array what you do is that
you look at a series of pulsars so a
pulsar is a neutron star that we talked
about earlier but now its spin axis is
misaligned with its magnetic field line
so every time it spins around it sends a
flash of radio waves to the Earth like a
lighthouse you get these really stable
flashes so we know exactly when those
flashes should arrive so stable just
means it's a good clock it's a almost
perfect clock before 2012 they were
better than atomic clocks okay pulsars
pulsars amazing very for the experts
it's a millisecond Pulsar but if you're
not an expert Pulsar is fine
just to just to be safe so is
millisecond a short period of time for a
pulsar or a long period it's very short
yeah it means that it spins around about
100 times a second okay and just to blow
your mind a little bit more these
millisecond pulsars are about one and a
half times the mass of the sun
and they spin around a hundred times a
second and they would fit into the
island of Manhattan
it'd be a bad idea though you do not
want that to happen absolutely not but
like a few miles ago they are they're
very exactly they're very small and 100
times a second that's right whenever I
like it because whenever we say they're
very small you know compared to what
they're they're much smaller than the
earth but they're more massive than the
sun exactly exactly but they are smaller
than Manhattan but the fact that they
spin around 100 times a second is
impressive right and they don't fly
apart because gravity is so strong right
that's right how many of these do we
know about
oh
there I mean there are thousands of
pulsars
um that we know of we there's
potentially tens of thousands of them in
the Milky Way galaxy alone
currently there's only about a hundred
of these pulsars that are good enough
clocks to look for gravitational waves
but I haven't yet told you how we use
them as gravitational wave detectors
thank you maybe I will so yes the the
pulsars are perfect clocks basically for
all intents and purposes and so you
measure
their time of arrival of the pulse at
the Earth you know when it should arrive
you've measured when they do arrive and
any change in when the pulse arrives
with respect to when it should arrive
could indicate the fact that now that
Pulsar is sitting on the other side of
the room and it got a little bit further
away from me and then it gets a little
bit closer so the Pulsar time arrivals
will change a little bit they can arrive
early and then they can arrive late
and so now when we're thinking about the
strain again if you're thinking about a
change in distance over distance ligo
style this is something like 10 meters
per light year but as humans it doesn't
really mean a lot right
really mean a lot and so it's in my
opinion more intuitive to think about a
change in time over time okay and that
is something like 100 nanoseconds over a
decade oh okay so small exactly a tiny
amount but that change is still a
million times stronger than the change
that a stellar Mass black hole merger
will give you in the ligo detectors okay
wait no I'm very confused now but okay
let's catch our bread that's bad so
that's bad what so the idea is that
there are all these different ways of
detecting gravitational waves yeah but
just like a telescope that there are
optical telescopes infrared telescopes
x-ray telescopes different wavelengths
they're looking at likewise the
gravitational wave telescopes are only
sensitive to certain wavelengths that's
right yes and ligo is sensitive to tens
to hundreds of Hertz Hertz and do you
know how many meters or kilometers that
corresponds to
no I don't know either so okay so it's
also complicated because
um that my experimentalist colleagues
will be very proud of me have known that
there are power recycling mirrors in the
ligo arms which effectively makes the
arms much longer than they actually are
which enables you to detect stronger
signals from these black hole mergers
right okay good so just to translate
that if detected that I understand it
the actual ligo arms are about four
kilometers in
apart or at least you know in length but
what you're saying is that they can
detect gravitational waves with
wavelengths longer than that because
they keep bouncing back and forth over
and over again potentially yeah yeah
okay good so what is relevant I think
you're right what is relevant is the
frequency in hertz not the wavelength
really the frequency is what we care
about okay so then say it again now that
I'm listening what was the what was the
frequency for the ligo for ligo it's uh
tens to hundreds of Hertz of Hertz okay
so yeah to hundreds of cycles per second
that's right whereas your Pulsar timing
arrays yes are sensitive to 1 to 100
nanohertz and Nano is so one Nano Hertz
is about
[Music]
um
30 years
like one over 30 years over 30 years
yeah right exactly so it would take 30
years for one full wave cycle to go by
and that roughly corresponds to the fact
that we're looking to pulsars scattered
throughout the Galaxy they're light
years away from us exactly and so
there's no other way to detect that we
know of right now these very low
frequency gravitational waves because
now if you think about well for a few
reasons
mainly these these gravitational waves
that are coming from supermassive black
holes are very low frequency or have
these very long wavelengths so something
on Earth could never detect a
gravitational wave that has a period of
decades okay right you just can't do it
so the so the ligo
detectors look at these in spiraling
black holes there were tens of solar
masses that's right and that's just what
they're sensitive to I mean there could
be black holes out there that are single
solar masses that are in spiraling or
thousands of solar masses that are in
spiraling and ligo just wouldn't know
that's right yeah okay and so we talked
a little bit about the leesa detector
earlier on when we were talking about
supermassive black hole seeds but in
fact Lisa is now sensitive to the
millihertz frequency regime which is
right in between ligo and Pulsar timing
arrays and so they would be able to
detect these thousand solar mass black
hole mergers but again like ligo will
not be able to detect that and neither
will pulse our timing arrays but Lisa is
scheduled to be launched and you said
2034 right now and it's never going to
happen obviously I mean it will happen
but it's not going to happen 2034
because no satellite has ever launched
the year they plan to launch it's
interesting that you should say that
because normally I would strongly agree
with you like vehemently that would be a
violent agreement with you but there are
some reasons that we might want to
launch Lisa earlier so number one
there's always this Pathfinder Mission
and Lisa's Pathfinder mission was it
performed you know extraordinarily
better it surpassed all expectations it
was an amazing flight so the technology
is ready to go
there's a an x-ray telescope called
Athena which is supposed to be launched
in 2028 okay and this x-ray telescope
would be the perfect instrument to try
to follow up on supermassive black hole
mergers that Lisa could see so if they
were to launch at roughly the same time
or at the very least be alive in space
at the same time you would have a huge
science case for you know looking at
these electromagnetic or like light
signals from merging supermassive black
holes and there might not be another
opportunity to do this in the near
future got it so there's a strong case
it's being made right now to move up the
Lisa launch date so that it can coincide
with Athena okay and Lisa is the set of
basically lasers in space lasers in
space exactly it's like it's called a
constellation because there's three
different points and it makes a triangle
and what's cool about this is that in
this triangle you can make two
independent ligo like detectors so you
can take your equilateral triangle and
make two independent right angle
interferometers from it
um and that means that as your
triangular configuration is circling the
earth and floating around it can detect
the polarization of your gravitational
wave okay and so this is exciting not
only for detecting polarization
information itself but because according
to general relativity there should only
be two gravitational wave polarizations
which are plus and cross so the plus
configuration is when you and I are
going
um now let's just imagine a
gravitational wave passing through our
human body you first are stretched up
and you look like a supermodel you're
very tall or a modern supermodel I
should say very tall very thin and then
you get squished down and stretched out
and then you look like a sumo wrestler
right and then you get stretched back up
again now you can plus exactly that's
the plus so you can rotate that by 45
degrees and you get cross
two polarization that's too polarization
so just like light but the the specifics
of how they're polarized are different
but light is either vertically or
horizontally polarized gravity waves
plus and plus and cross
yes well so exactly but there's some
alternative theories of gravity which
predict more polarization so something
like a breathing mode and that would be
um like a circle kind of breathing out
and then Contracting back in on itself
so imagine a sphere getting bigger and
then collapsing like a long breathing
but it's this circular polarization well
it's like a
a circle pattern that's breathing in and
out well what I guess the point is that
the regular gravitational waves
they stretch in One Direction but also
squeezing the other yeah you're saying
that these fancy non-general relativity
hypothetical waves stretch in every
direction and then squeezing that's
right yeah but they don't exist on their
own it's an addition it's like you have
plus and cross and breathing
and so we got to there by saying that
Lisa could potentially
disentangle this ligo could potentially
as well if you have enough
interferometers and if you're lucky with
the orientation of your Source because
you'll always have
problem where you have more sensitivity
to some polarizations than others by how
your Source your gravitational wave
source is facing the Earth right because
those gravitational waves and interact
with your antennas and your antennas are
going to be more or less sensitive to
different orientations of your
gravitational wave sources so it sounds
like so far would like so we got to
separate out what we've done from what
we're hoping to do right yes ligo is
detective thing Sligo has detected
things absolutely as unequivocally Lisa
has not detected anything yet exactly
um and we've not yet
figured out the polarization of
gravitational waves so it seems like
mostly what we have is consistent with
our expectations but it's hard to do
detailed tests of general relativity of
general relativity were modified a
little bit it would still be consistent
what we've seen so far
yeah this I mean this is a really
interesting point there's lots of
different modifications that you can
make to general relativity and so so far
the polarization ones
um there's no red flags but you can also
make modifications to the waveform and
those can be very subtle and can
sometimes they're only detectable in the
inspiral part of the gravitational wave
signal so before the whoop chirp at the
end of the life you can get small
changes that are happening in the in
spiral when it's not chirping so much
but that part is really difficult to
detect because it's very low frequency
and at low frequencies on Earth you're
dominated by you know things like clouds
passing over ahead of your detector very
sensitive detection Newtonian noise uh
you know you have earthquakes you have
trucks driving by you have alligators
that can crash in Louisiana is exactly
yeah so there's a lot of things that can
go wrong so right now a lot of the very
low frequency information is lost in
that in that noise but future detectors
like the Einstein telescope which is
being proposed
um
or uh you know it's another
gravitational wave yes or Cosmic
Explorer these will all have very good
low frequency noise capabilities So the
plan is to bury them underground to do a
better job at controlling those kinds of
noise sources okay you did say earlier
speaking of predictions of general
relativity that the gravitational waves
move at the speed of light yes how do we
know that well
if there's any justice in the universe
they should have but there might not be
we've been in the universe lately
there's not a lot of Justice
way to keep it real Sean way to keep it
real
you are right uh so there's only
recently been uh verification of this
prediction that gravity travels at the
speed of light by a binary neutron star
merger that was seen so not a black hole
it was not a black hole it was two
neutron stars that were merging with
each other and
um we saw the light and the
gravitational wave signal from that
system and the light arrived
2 times 10 to the minus 15 seconds after
the gravitational wave signal so that's
two parts and a million billion so we
know almost the same time that for it's
pretty good it's pretty it's pretty much
the same time
so so the black holes merge we don't see
anything with electromagnetic waves
of course everyone has a theory where
you could possibly see something but in
in very straight gr there's no
expectation of seeing an electromagnetic
counterpart in fact it's one of the
things when I first started studying
gravitational waves it really blew my
mind is that gravitational waves it's
another Spectrum it has nothing to do
with light and
it's you know people also call it
gravitational radiation that's another
word that's used synonymously
um that took me a long time to
understand as well that gravitational
radiation is gravitational waves but you
can
it's much easier to think about
electromagnetic radiation and
gravitational radiation they each have
their own spectrum they but they're
different they're intrinsically
different like you can have one
Source like a light bulb but that's
emitting multiple frequencies right
multiple different wavelengths you can
look at it with an infrared camera you
can look at it with Optical with your
eyes but with a gravitational wave
Source it's really going to be
restricted to its own part of the
gravitational wave spectrum you're not
going to have two merging black holes of
any mass that are going to give you
simultaneously different gravitational
wave signals it's just a continuous way
of generating these gravitational wave
signals and in part that's just because
gravity is a much Dumber Force than
electromagnetism I mean it's not
positive and negative gravitational
charges it's just lumps of matter and
energy and they're doing something at a
certain frequency and that's where
they're going to radiate nothing
complicated about it exactly yeah okay
and so although I object to calling it
dumb I feel like you're hurting the
black holes feelings so if someone's
going to speak up on their behalf I will
it's straightforward let's say that it's
there's not a lot of cancellation of
subtle effects but for the neutron star
neutron star merger so how many of those
have we found one only one okay yeah
that's just one special yeah it's very
special
um but there you get both gravitational
waves and an explosion that is very
visible in light yes that's right that's
why we can tell the speed of them coming
to us is the same that's right and we've
been able to monitor the remnant
afterwards to see like how the light is
evolving to see what materials were
produced when the two neutron stars
merged in fact I think it was on the
front page of the Wall Street Journal
because it would have created vast
amounts of gold and platinum if you
could speculators go live travel out
there exactly yeah okay good so we so
general relativity once again pretty
good shape yes it's in very good shape
okay good buy my book I wrote a book
about it yeah
um I did so good very good that's one uh
so sorry we have ligo we Now understand
Lisa is going to happen in the future
and Lisa what is the main target for
Lisa going to be Lisa will look at
uh intermediate Mass black holes and
supermassive black hole mergers
and
um it'll also look at things called
Extreme Mass ratio in spirals or emeries
and that means that the ratio of the two
masses will be something like a thousand
or ten thousand to one and tiny black
hole falling to a big Buckle exactly and
then those create really interesting
gravitational wave signatures
um so it can look at those it can look
at these intermediate Mass block holes
and it can look at supermassive black
hole mergers so the point the point of
Lisa depends on who you ask sure so
people like me who study super massive
black holes say clearly we want to look
for the baby supermassive black holes
the ones that are a million times the
mass of the sun because the billion
solar mass ones you find with Pulsar
timing arrays right okay so their
frequencies are too low to be increases
banned not only that but they don't
exist because there's another thing that
we haven't spoken about yet okay there's
something called the innermost stable
circular orbit of a black hole binary
system
and well of any black hole really but
the same thing holds true for Black Hole
binary systems and that's just the
the last stable orbit that any kind of
body can orbit around right and so if
you have two merging billion solar mass
block holes can say they're roughly uh
the same mass
they will merge at a millionth of a
Hertz at 10 to the minus 6 Hertz and so
what that means is that it merges in the
space in between Pulsar timing and Lisa
so those black holes will never make it
to the Lucid band they merge first so
they're Isco frequency for the experts
who might be listening is 10 to the
minus 6 Hertz and so you're right in
between experiments
okay well you know that's only given
human Ingenuity not yet up to the task
of finding a way to look at that band
right but okay I'm actually a big fan of
the uh uh
tiny black holes falling into the
supermassive ones yeah because that lets
you map out the space-time metric around
the big black hole and that would really
test general relativity absolutely
that'd be great yes I look forward to
you doing that I'm a big fan of Lisa for
exactly that reason I think that uh you
know it was it almost went away I
remember I was on a NASA panel that
really pushed for Lisa but it was
decided that it was you know a little
speculative the technology we didn't
know and it wasn't until ligo found
gravitational waves at all people said
oh wait we got to do this now right well
there's also the elephant in the room
that's the James Webb Space Telescope
that took all the money I know but maybe
it's not polite to talk about that now
no but there's a good amount of money it
there is a finite amount of money but
it's not a fixed amount of money
I mean Congress can decide to pay for
two things they don't generally when
they cancel one big science project give
the savings to other science projects
yeah so I I kind of I mean it's true
that there are priorities we have to
decide what to do but it's I think that
scientists often think that their
project is fighting against other
science projects when it's really
usually not the case
you're right you're right in that sense
it's not a zero-sum game you could
always get more money so that that's a
really good point
um in the case of Lisa I think that we
owe a huge debt of gratitude to the
European Space Agency which then took on
the entire project and kept it alive and
after the Lago detection as you
mentioned NASA is now rejoined as a
junior partner that's what you get but
but that's also great because the
European Space Agency couldn't afford
the full Lisa so it would have only had
two arms
uh and now that NASA has rejoined it's
back to full three-armed Lisa so all
right three arms Lisa in the 2030s maybe
well but right here and now so just to
finish the retinue here we have ligo
that has already won the Nobel Prize
Lisa is in the pipeline but we have your
Pulsar timing arrays which is going
right now right it's not only is it
going right now but my colleagues have
been timing these millisecond pulsars
for decades okay so some of the Pulsar
timing Baseline span almost 30 years and
nanograph which is the North American
nanohertz Observatory for gravitational
waves
um has been operating for the last 15
years timing these millisecond pulsars
in a very
um strategic way to detect gravitational
waves and so as a gravitational wave
detector Pulsar timing arrays are also
really unique because you know we talked
about how one Pulsar will have an
advance or a delay in its arrival time
but the Galaxy is full of pulsars right
and so by using pulsars in this way
you're turning the whole galaxy into a
gravitational wave detector which is
really kind of mind-blowing but that is
exactly what we're doing and so if you
were to see this advance or delay just
in one pulsar
you can't really conclude anything
because your pulsars are thousands of
light years away and there's gas in the
Galaxy there's dust right your you know
wavelengths are affected in different
ways by by these processes you can have
things that scatter so you have to look
for the signal not only in one Pulsar
but in a whole array of pulsars and so
right now there's about a hundred of
them that are timed by the international
Pulsar timing array so not only
nanograph it'll so the European Pulsar
timing array the parks Pulsar timing
array and the new Indian Pulsar timing
array
and so we're collaborating and we're
trying to create a new data set which
joins together all of our data for these
pulsars because you're um sensitivity to
detecting gravitational wave scales as
the number of pulsars and as the square
root of the time so you should always
add more pulsars before sitting and just
waiting
and the good news is this is my naivete
as the theory is showing through but you
don't need to build anything to do this
you just use existing telescopes right
yes I think that's been a blessing and a
curse for Pulsar timing arrays because
it's such an ingenious idea which
actually had its Inception in the early
days of of um space travel so uh sazen
wrote this paper in 1979 describing how
you could use the Doppler shifting of
signals from potential
probes leaving the solar system to look
for gravitational waves wow isn't that
it's so clever right that you can use
spacecraft and time delays from
spacecraft but then he was very you know
disappointed that you know you don't
really have the timing Precision that
would enable that kind of detection
and
then
there's this Serendipity that happened
with Pulsar timing as well that in 1982
the very first millisecond Pulsar was
discovered and in 1983 there was this
paper that came out very early on like
in January that said if only we had
pulsars that were good enough we could
create a pulsar timing array but
unfortunately none of the pulsars are
precise enough none of them have this
kind of you know 100 nanosecond timing
stability over a decade but back in the
day in the early 80s you know you
actually had to read physical journals
and so there's a little bit of overlap
and there's there's a little footnote in
the bottom of that paper saying you know
like actually maybe it's possible wow
yeah and that was in early 1983 yeah
it's all about timing but um back to
your comment about this being a cheap
experiment I think it has been a
blessing and a curse the idea is
beautiful I think it's really an Insight
it's a fantastic idea it's my favorite
kind of it still Thrills me to this day
to think that like one of us very clever
Apes thought about doing that yeah
um it's also a curse in the sense that
it is very cheap and I think that that
makes people take it less seriously I
think that if you know uh the National
Science Foundation had invested billions
of dollars in this experiment over the
last few decades that it would have a
much higher profile than it does right
now
um of course that kind of investment
also enables lots of public Outreach and
a huge machine behind the experiment but
in fact in the last
um few years the National Science
Foundation has invested heavily in
nanograph and so we received a physics
Frontier Center award for 15 million
dollars
um about six or seven years ago was the
first one and it was just renewed uh two
years ago for 17 million dollars and so
this is the biggest investment in Pulsar
timing arrays directly on the planet so
we are very grateful uh for you know
this money to enable the experiment and
um you know to pay for students and
postdocs and researchers and Telescope
time but ligo is a billion dollars but
ligo was at least a billion dollars and
and so yeah I think that there's this
kind of interesting psychology right
that happens when you have an investment
that's that big and something and there
was at least a chance 10 years ago that
you would have found gravitational waves
before ligo
it was a neck and neck contest we
thought and in fact
there's another funny story about that
so in 2015 people you know in September
2015 there was the very first
gravitational wave event and of course
scientists get very excited and so
people accidentally leave uh pre-prints
on a printer paper drafts are lying all
over the place and people are of course
just calling their friends and telling
them unless you're Kip Thorne who didn't
tell his wife
look he lived a long time just to make
this moment happen he was not going to
ruin it with loose lips at the end yeah
exactly exactly but everyone else is
very excited and like I heard about it
at The Red Door uh the cafe at Caltech
exactly when I was a postdoc there
at the same time there was a signal in
the nanograph 11-year data that looked a
hell of a lot like a gravitational wave
background signal so I haven't told you
yet what a gravitational wave background
is but if we just go with the fact that
there was a signal in the data and it
was basically a race against when does
ligo see the first binary black hole
merger and when does uh when do Pulsar
timing arrays or nanograph see the this
random gravitational wave background
no one knew what the answer was because
no one knew what nature did like no one
knows how many merging supermassive
black holes there are what the amplitude
of the background is and no one knows
what their merger rates are for real
binary black holes I mean before the
first Lego detection this varied by
orders of magnitude every year you would
get new papers that had different wild
estimates so people just kind of threw
their hands up in the air and they're
like the Margaritas whatever you think
it is like
who knows it ended up like I was pretty
lucky with a bunch of black hole mergers
ligo was so lucky so it's ligo in terms
of these ground-based experiments but we
should also be careful there was also
there's the Virgo detector in Italy and
that helps with triangulation when you
can see there's there's two Lego
detectors in the US there's one in Italy
and there's also one in Japan called
kagra
um CAG was cool because it has Sapphire
mirrors
that's cool I guess that's cool
it doesn't look like a sapphire like you
can't put a ring on it but it is very
cool yeah
um but yeah Lego got really lucky with
the first detection because it was
screaming loud and I did uh some of my
PhD work on ligo and I know for a fact
that people have been working for many
many years on creating very sensitive
data analysis Pipelines
to tease out the hint of a gravitational
wave signal and have very sophisticated
Bayesian analysis techniques to look for
the evidence in every sense of the word
for this signal
and the first one was so loud you could
see it by eye and no one would believe
it they were like did someone shake the
mirror like guys for real did someone
just put this in were we hacked like
what what happened and uh it was just a
screaming loud gravitational wave signal
so at that time there was also a signal
in the nanograph 11-year data this is
the Pulsar time this is the Pulsar
timing array and we were like oh my gosh
might get there first
um are we gonna scoop I go which would
be so fun in the sense that uh you know
our little experiment that had you know
very limited funding was now competed it
was like a David and Goliath kind of
situation and so internally we were like
um maybe you should have enjoyed press
conference
imagining like yeah what we're gonna do
with Pulsar timing arrays and
um and then ligo starts kind of slinging
mud in a collegial wave of course but
like saying like it's not a direct
detection like you're not making
anything that's direct we have a
waveform and we're like
that's not super true like we're looking
at the change in times of pulsars and
you're like looking at the change in
distance and signals and we know that
you know gr is right so yeah that's the
same thing you do not have a more direct
detector
so anyhow there was a lot of weird kind
of backroom conversations but in the end
this 11-year signal
um
was likely due to solar system ephemeris
errors because 11 years is roughly the
period of Jupiter oh I was gonna say it
was a sunspot cycle but no it's
because you don't care about sun spots
because it's gravitational waves but you
do care about your location in the solar
system you do care about your location
in the solar system and that's because
you know if you think about where like
how you're timing pulsars the Earth is
moving throughout the solar system
throughout the year the pulsars are
moving on the sky so you want to take
your time of arrival stamps for your
pulsars and transform them to the solar
system Berry Center the Berry Center is
where you can balance the solar system
on the tip of your finger right that's
the point you want all of your time of
arrivals or your toas to be at that
point you can trust everything at that
point
if there's a mistake in how you
calculate that point
um what happens is that your Pulsar
arrival times will circulate the kind of
like orbit the True Berry Center and
create this signal that's present in all
of your pulsars
but it won't have the gravitational wave
shape to it that we expected which is a
quadrupole it'll have a dipole signature
but not the quadruple so that's good
because it's sort of a check that you
haven't yeah unless there is so much
dipole signal that it leaks
into the quadrupole in your data
analysis and that's actually what we
found
um we found that there was this you know
it could be something like eccentricity
there was some sort of error in the
position in massive Jupiter that was
perturbing the solar system very center
and once um my colleague at JPL Michaela
valesneri wrote this software to correct
for this the signal went away okay so
has nanograph detected something have
they announced the detection you don't
have to tell us any secrets but I mean
publicly have Pulsar timing arrays found
any gravitational waves yet so publicly
there is a lot of excitement about the
last round of papers that have come out
from nanograph from the European Pulsar
timing array and from the parks Pulsar
timing Ray and then together from the
international Pulsar timing Ura everyone
has found a signal
that has an amplitude that would signify
that it comes from a gravitational wave
background right the amplitude is
commensurate with what we would expect
theoretically to come from the cosmic
merger history of supermassive black
holes so maybe I should take a second to
just dig into that
so if you have you know One Source
emitting gravitational waves you can
detect that one source on the sky but
now imagine you have Galaxy mergers that
are happening all over the place and
then they are not only happening all
over the place but they've been
happening for a long time
so you now get a buildup of signals in
your in each one of the frequency bins
that you're sensitive to and so this
creates a stochastic or random
gravitational wave background
so you not only have one signal but you
have potentially tens of thousands of
signals so you don't measure just one
merging supermassive black hole but you
measure the amplitude of all of this
um gravitational wave signal that's
interfering with itself for lack of a
better so just to be clear we have the
cosmic microwave background which are
photons and they literally were all
bumping into each other and bumping into
atoms and and it's all over the place
this is totally different totally
different and it's it you call it a
background just because it's coming from
many individual sources that are sort of
like as far as our detectors are
concerned it's one big smoosh on the sky
that's right
um but if we want to get technical it is
a foreground it is the signal that we're
looking for but someone 30 years ago
called it a background and we've been
calling it that ever since yeah but for
anyone that studies these things you are
right yes it is a foreground and they're
they're from supermassive black hole
mergers what kind of mergers are we
talking about yeah so if the sources are
astrophysical then yes it would come
from supermassive black hole mergers
however people are very creative and
it's possible that there there's also
gravitational waves from inflation
um
exactly primordial gravitational waves
which could either be part of the signal
or the whole signal
if it were the whole signal then we
would be in a very strange Universe
where we would have a big balance and a
big a big crunch
um thought I know that you know all
about this Sean that you would be in a
kind of ekparatic style universe and
crazier things like cosmic strings would
give you gravitational waves and cosmic
strings also give you gravitational
waves and a gravitational wave
background and so in fact what we have
right now is that there's this amplitude
of a gravitational wave background that
we've found but right now the way that
you distinguish between what's
generating the background is how that
amplitude evolves as a function of
frequency so as you go to higher and
higher frequencies how does that
amplitude vary
and right now we don't have enough
measurements in different frequency bins
to say exactly how that signal is
evolving so we can't say for sure that
that signal would be from supermassive
black hole binaries that would have a
very finite like f to the minus two
thirds dependence the problem is that a
primordial background would be
-1 and cosmic strings would be like
minus 7 8
supermassive black holes is minus
two-thirds so everything is about minus
one if everything is about minus one so
it's not like ligo where there was a big
press conference that I was at you know
they announced the thing it's something
where it's gonna creep up on us there's
already been papers saying maybe we're
beginning to see the tens of this yeah
so right now we think that it's a hint
potentially of a gravitational wave
background signal because there's two
parts to a detection with Pulsar timing
so the first part is this amplitude you
see the same amplitude in all the
pulsars that you're timing that rules
out anything else that could possibly be
talking to all of these pulsars in the
Galaxy at the same time right there's
nothing else right they have different
noises and so we we cross correlate all
of the pulsars in our array because as
you do this cross-correlation anything
that's not common and the pulsars Falls
away and only the common signal is left
afterwards and so this cross-correlation
is important for two reasons you get
what this amplitude is of the
gravitational wave background and as you
said correctly this is something that
builds up very slowly as a function of
time and so we call this red noise
so what we technically right now call
the signal that we found is a common red
noise process
and that just means that it is a low
frequency signal that's in all of the
pulsars
we're not sure what it is it looks
promising it could be something other
than one but it could be something else
right we have to be very careful now the
second thing that you get from doing
this cross-correlation search
is this correlation function it's kind
of a two-point correlation function so
basically when you correlate any two
Pulsar pairs general relativity tells
you what this expected correlation
function value is for any given Pulsar
pair you have to explain what a
correlation function is yeah so if I
have pulsars that are separated by a
certain angle on the sky
um they can have
uh say let's just start with a positive
and negative correlation so if the
pulsars are positively correlated it's
like doing you know a fist bump in the
air with both of your hands at the same
time you go up and down they are
positively correlated you expect those
Pulsar signals to be you know positively
correlated when you're seeing one you'll
expect to see the other yeah you see
them both moving at the same time so
they're positively correlated but if
your pulsars are separated by something
like 80 degrees then they're going to be
anti-correlated so one is coming kind of
closer to you the other one is moving
away but it's a negative or an
anti-correlation because of this Plus or
cause polarization if you're stretching
space time in One Direction you're
squeezing it in the oven that's right
it's not it's that but integrated over
the whole Sky yeah so
and so
that which we call spatial correlations
that has not been found by anyone yet
and that's going to be the Smoking Gun
and after we find that that's when we'll
have a big press release and make a huge
you know far but everything okay very
good yes but right now we have one piece
of the puzzle which is this amplitude
um which is the same in all the pulsars
and in fact now we have
um as I explained a little bit earlier
the signal that comes from nanograph but
also the Europeans found the same signal
and the Australians found the same
signal and we do not use the same
telescopes we do time some of the same
pulsars in the northern hemisphere so
there's some overlap between Europe and
nanograph but in the southern hemisphere
it's very difficult for anyone in the
northern hemisphere to time those
pulsars so it's curious that we found a
consistent amplitude
uh
and it's also curious as to what that
tells us if it does come from
supermassive black holes it means that
the final parsec problem that we talked
about doesn't exist
that none of them none of them stalled
none of the black holes got hung up they
all managed to merge very fluidly
because if they if there is a hang up if
they do stall
then this decreases the amplitude of the
gravitational wave Background by about
30 percent
and so the only way to get two black
holes that have stalled to eventually
merge in the absence of anything else is
to realize you know we believe that in
the universe we have these hierarchical
Galaxy mergers eventually a third Galaxy
is going to show up with its own
supermassive black hole you're going to
have this three-body interaction and the
least massive black hole
the least massively yeah wait yes gets
ejected from the system and the
remaining to merge
so they always merge sometimes would
just take them a very long time to merge
and so if there is that kind of stalling
or if there's not enough Stars if
there's not enough gas
that decreases the amplitude of the
background by about 30 percent but for
what we're seeing right now really is
from supermassive black holes it's
completely inconsistent with with any
kind of stalling so the universe finds a
way to make supermassive black holes
merge on a very reasonable time scale in
fact it's so reasonable that the signal
was first seen in the international
Pulsar timing or a data three years ago
maybe four years ago now
and we were like that can't be right
this has got to be something in like the
telescope back end there's something
weird happening here this is not crazy
talk exactly no it's not but we were
just like we just were not ready
to admit that like what we're seeing was
potentially this signal because it was
so loud
so we were you know and and people in my
field have been writing papers for years
about like why we haven't seen the
gravitational wave background yet like
is it because they're stalling it's
because supermassive black hole masses
have all been overestimated are they not
so massive and on and on and on and you
know I've that's why I got interested in
this whole problem in the first place is
like why haven't we seen anything yet
but it was there potentially yeah but
maybe not but what we really need to do
is find those spatial correlations
um that come from our correlation
function that we use so a lot of fields
of science use these correlation
functions sure
um and you have a prediction for what
the value should be you measure what it
actually is
and so just to you know take a step back
because this is very
um it's fascinating stuff and like you
like you very accurately conveyed it is
a Triumph of human Ingenuity to figure
this out it's like almost like we have a
spider web spread throughout the near
regions of our galaxies connecting us to
these pulsars and we're feeling the
vibrations right that's how I had Ed
Young on the podcast recently he was
talking about all the different ways
that different animals sense the world
and yeah spiders feel vibrations in
their webs and it just reminds me of
that like we're feeling the vibrations
in the web of pulsars exactly and the
wavelengths of gravitational waves that
are doing what we care about are tens of
light years so you know visible light is
very tiny wavelength microwaves are a
centimeter or whatever and this is tens
of light years wavelength and we might
be able to be detecting we might be able
we might be detecting it already that's
right that's right and that's why it
takes so long to make one of those
detections because you have to for an
individual Source wait for you know one
wave cycle to go by and for the
gravitational wave background what you
do is that you get more and more
sensitive to the background
um as the number of pulsars you include
in your array and then as the square
root of the time so you can try to add
more pulsars but you're not guaranteed
that if you get telescope time and
pointed at the sky that you're going to
find the pulsars that you need right so
then you just keep timing the pulses
that you have and you also keep trying
to find new ones but then
um because you need such a long time
spans to get to very low sensitivities
because you're the bucket of your
experiment or the lowest frequency that
you're sensitive to is one over your
total time
and so the larger your total time the
lower the frequency you can get to and
so you want to have very long time spans
you want to have as many pulsars as you
can that's why the international
collaboration is so important because
you not only increase your time spans
but you increase your number of pulsars
and you can also increase you know the
density of the data points that you have
because people have been timing
different pulsars at different times so
if you can combine all of that data you
get this denser data stream that's going
to be particularly useful for finding
the individual sources well okay good
that was my next question because it
would be a different thing if all these
waves that we were detecting came from
One Source right then I presume that
then the sort of spatial pattern would
be much easier to perceive but it's sort
of a cacophony from all directions right
is there a hope of eventually
disentangling that and saying okay here
are the locations of the loudest sources
how feasible is it to imagine going from
oh there's a whole washed out background
to oh I'm beginning to perceive there's
a bright spot sure yeah okay
so if you want to detect a gravitational
wave background you do this
cross-correlation search and you look
for this correlation function that
should exist but if you want to look for
individual sources what you actually do
is that you look for right now we look
for sinusoidal waves in the individual
Pulsar timing data and so we don't look
for cross-correlations and the Pulsar
data right now to look for the
individual sources
so the individual ones could be
relatively nearby
um
there's been a lot of research done to
try to understand
if we're going to detect like a single
Source first or the gravitational wave
background first
almost everyone agrees that it's the
gravitational wave background because in
the background you have you know the
cosmic merger history of all of the
supermassive black holes that's a lot of
gravitational wave power that's going
into those low frequencies but if you
have one black hole binary system that's
relatively nearby then that will swamp
your other signal so like which one is
it so it looks like
we might have seen the first hint of
something happening for the background
which means we now have to find a way to
subtract it
to get rid of that noise so we can see
what's underneath right right okay and
what's underneath will be likely either
an individual Source or it could be
anisotropy in the gravitational wave
background similar to The Cosmic
microwave background how they have those
beautiful maps of hot spots and cold
spots you could have something similar
for Pulsar timing arrays where you have
parts of the sky that have more merging
supermassive black hole binaries in
other parts of the sky or maybe there's
one that's nearby that's not quite
detectable on its own but might leave a
huge blemish in the gravitational wave
Background by leaving some Excess power
in that part of the sky will we be able
to get anything about the
Epoch of most of these mergers I mean
with his question of uh how do the
mergers happen so how are we going to do
science to use Pulsar timing arrays to
help answer that kind of question yeah
that's a great question so when you're
Computing
um the amplitude of what you expect the
gravitational wave background to be
there the two main ingredients are
number one what the black hole mass is
and then number two what's the number
density of supermassive black holes that
you have
and so the number density tells you you
know I have a certain volume how many
supermassive black hole binaries do I
have in that volume and so that's a
number that you can play with and as you
go out further and further and further
you'll have more and more and more
supermassive black holes and so given
the fact that when you try to
theoretically estimate the amplitude of
the background you have those two big
ingredients when you actually detect the
gravitational wave background you can
try to tease out those two quantities so
what's the minimum Black Hole Mass
that's contributing to the gravitational
wave background and what's the number
density of these as a function of
distance or redshift in the universe it
goes very quickly from you discovered
something new and completely
unanticipated or at least uh
unprecedented I should say to this is an
everyday tool we're going to use to
understand the universe better right
yeah exactly I think unanticipated is
not quite right as in it's been
anticipated for 15 years at least it's
been it's been so long in fact the first
paper was written um on using this cross
correlation cross correlation search in
1983.
so it's okay it's been a while yeah so
do you closing thoughts do you recommend
that uh young people who are interested
in the frontier of astrophysics think
about this kind of thing is something to
learn more about
so young people interested in the
frontiers of astrophysics should do what
whatever they think is the coolest thing
that they can think of and for me when I
was a kid it was black holes and I
started working on the ligo experiment
when I was a graduate student and then I
um thought that maybe Pulsar timing
arrays were a place where I could make
more of a mark because it felt like ligo
was already very saturated sure it was a
very mature field and I was like this is
a bit of a gamble but like
what if I can make some sort of big
contribution to this new field
um so I've I've been doing it before it
was cool Sean oh yeah but now it's
extremely cool if it now it's extremely
cool so I I think you know but the only
reason that you can ever make it through
a PhD is if you really love what it is
that you're working on and so my advice
would to just be like find the coolest
thing you can think of and do that thing
cannot think of a better place to end
than that Kiara mingarelli thanks so
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thanks Sean it's a pleasure
[Music]